they're sneaky they're slimy
and they're hungry for meat
the hagfish or slime eel has earned its
name
due to its unique defense mechanism
when they're agitated hagfish can
secrete slime
to choke unsuspecting predators
even sharks fall prey to their gunky
wrath
this makes us wonder what would happen
if you fell into a pool full of them
what makes the hagfish so unique
how does hagfish slime expand so rapidly
and why is the hagfish useful to us
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you fell into a pool of hagfish
hagfish have been around for hundreds of
millions of years and
are the only known living animal with a
skull
but no spine they are also
jawless creatures with the unique
ability to absorb nutrients
through their skin using four sets of
teeth on their tongue
hagfish like to burrow inside sea
creatures
dead and alive and digest them over time
their bodies are lined with special
glands that
secrete stringy proteins when the
hagfish feels agitated
this slime can expand 10 000 times
larger in under a second
making it a lethal choking hazard to
predators
so could you survive in a pool full of
them
[Music]
many hobbyists are actually turning
their pools into self-sustaining
ecosystems
for fish and plants known as an
aquaponic system
if you're feeling adventurous and want
to adopt hundreds of hagfish
you'll need a cold saltwater pool to
mimic their natural habitat
and enough dead fish to feed them in the
unfortunate event that you
slip and fall into the pool you might
still be okay
if you're close to the surface as bottom
dwellers
they may not even react to you being
there but
if you happen to disturb them the water
would start to get very slimy very
quickly
making it difficult to swim
the slime isn't actually sticky but it
is particularly strong it would tangle
around your toes
fingers ears and the crevices of your
body
if it got in your mouth and started to
expand in your throat
you could choke very quickly and drown
eventually the hagfish would feast on
your body
that's not exactly a nice way to go also
you might want to be extra careful if
you're driving near
trucks full of hagfish yes
hagfish slime is amusing like snot
except that it doesn't dry out
[Music]
can someone give me a tissue please the
mucin is made up of long
fibers like spider silk which are
arranged in small
bundles known as skeins when these
skeins come into contact with seawater
the glue holding them together dissolves
and the slime
expands rapidly these slime microfibers
are stronger than nylon thinner than
human hair
and one hundred thousand times softer
than jello
this makes hagfish slime an
exceptionally useful and
environmentally friendly fabric in fact
it's used to make
safety helmets kevlar vests and even
airbags
and researchers are investigating
whether it could be used as a
hydrogel to hold water in soil
for farming hagfish are also considered
a delicacy in
korean cuisine and are used in many
delicious stir-fry recipes
so maybe if you're careful you could
harvest them as a business
whatever the situation is if you're
swimming deep in the ocean
be aware of the many risks involved you
might even come face to
face with a giant squid
[Music]
but that's a story for another
what if
[Music]
you